welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is houston
so far the podcast has made
354 thousand dollars
almost wow not bad good guess we if we
divide that by two
uh then you would have been right 153
000 ad revenue not bad yeah for 70 weeks
yeah it's not bad at all oh that counts
down you count down to the weeks
i feel like that's more that's more
appropriate yeah yeah weeks 70 weeks
yeah like a year and a half yeah right
yeah but i mean if you break it down
weekly revenue right i guess so pretty
much the way to do it it's easier to
multiply so the next person on the
podcast can just add like ten thousand
dollars this is true and then they might
that's smart so every week you just add
10 000 and you're doing good yeah well
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast today this is something i've
been really interested in talking to you
about because you have uh first of all a
very unique youtube channel where you
rent out some of the world's most
expensive cars
and people will either wreck them or you
wind up making a lot of money from
renting these cars on a daily basis
sometimes hourly basis how many cars do
you have at this point that you rent out
you know that changes so much because
cars are coming and going but i
typically keep between 50 and 80 cars
and that's a collection of exotic cars
hyper cars sports cars suvs luxury cars
and then you know you have the auto
cycles
so everything combined between 50 and
80. it's kind of seasonal right you
don't want to have 100 auto cycles in
december when it's a little too cold and
then you don't want to have 100 in the
summer when it's 200 degrees outside so
it fluctuates quite a bit but
the youtube channel is predominantly now
i mean it's kind of overrun by all the
bad
that
in the beginning i made the youtube
channel and i was like so excited i
would go and film all the times i'd buy
a new car and you know save up the money
and build my business yeah and now it's
just turned into all the bad things that
are happening so
example of that well like
what stands out the last uh six months
so i'll i'll actually give you like a
little sneak peek these videos aren't
out yet but i can now talk about them
we
were the first company in the entire
world to have a huracan sto
for rent
and the third or fourth renter
drove a little bit too aggressive next
to a construction site and jumped off
the side of the road
the car was essentially totaled all the
body panels there was like a couple
hundred grand in damage
so the insurance company accepts
liability takes about six months yeah we
go we take it we get it fixed
uh one of my employees picked it up
about three weeks ago and drove out of
the body shop
wore a woman with twenty thousand
dollars worth of insurance policy hit
the front end no one minute after
getting this thing are you serious and
basically totaled it again
i hate to interrupt did he not see this
this lady come what was he missing
he was at a stop light yeah and the
light had turned green he went to go and
we have it on camera actually it's a
very vague camera there was a guy with a
dash cam behind him um but uh she runs a
red light and takes the front of the car
out just like that
and it's it's so unfortunate because
there's 146 thousand dollars of
additional damage that we only are going
to get 20 000 for
and
when you rent cars insurance is so
complicated
it's actually my best interest to not
file a claim on my own insurance
because right now
that my insurance policy is like about
800 to a million dollars a year
with any claim i've never had a claim
with any claim oh my god i'm literally
like scared
out of my mind to file because i think
they're going to either drop me
or they're going to raise the rates like
20
which could be 200 000 a year since the
pandemic it's just all bad
like anybody in the rental car business
i kind of feel bad for you guys you know
it's not the the best time to be there
so it costs you a million dollars a year
just to insure your vehicles it does and
like i said that fluctuates so now it's
really funny i had a conversation on the
way over here in the car
with uh i have a partner in the business
he's an orthopedic surgeon
and uh i told him i said we now have to
look at our business
not in terms of what each vehicle
revenues us but what it costs to ensure
so about a year ago uh so i'm sorry 2020
went by too quick so a year and a half
ago our insurance was about 400 000 a
year for the same coverage since the
pandemic and this is nationwide right i
mean these insurance companies aren't
just local to las vegas they don't just
do like four or five companies they're
doing hundreds of companies across the
board and they
decided to basically say
take it or leave it we're gonna cancel
you or you're gonna pay like three times
the rate
and companies like mine who kind of have
like a long track record i mean i'm
seven years in the business now
i don't really have the option to just
close up shop right and just start a new
business you know i'm kind of we've got
employees we've got bought long leases
we've got a huge business you know so it
was for me i had to accept that raise in
rates uh in november so now since
november of 2021 yeah the rates have
been three times the price
so yeah we're paying almost a million
bucks two and a half times the price wow
uh so when you're talking about revenues
on each car what's the most profitable
one a huracan and that's why i have like
14 of them right so a huracan is the
easiest car to use yeah right it's
easiest car to drive and it's the most
approachable for anybody that wants to
try an exotic car for the first time
right it's basically like a huracan and
like a rolls-royce cullinan because the
cullinan's like the one that fits the
most people so
typically a family would rent that car
and they would take it for multiple days
and the cullinan being such a new car
doesn't depreciate as much so we're able
to
obviously make more money if it doesn't
depreciate right and huracans are pretty
much the same because they're so
reliable
people buy them for higher value used
right 14 000 miles on a mclaren is
totally different than 14 000 miles on a
lamborghini right and i mean i think you
know that because you're a car guy and
every specialty specialty car
depreciates so much more aggressive
than like the
general
lamborghini mass production car i mean
essentially huracan's the most mass and
widely produced exotic car right as was
the gallardo you know so it's like kind
of that similar mid-engine lamborghini
that way so how much you buy the car for
and how much does it rent out a day or
how much how much revenue does that
bring in a month
so
we'll break it down by car okay right
and we'll use the general car the
huracan is a great example because
the base price of a huracan is
mediocre about 250 000
i order every car brand new every single
car in my fleet i order myself i spec my
own options i have orders up until 2024
currently wow so my business is all
planned out just two three almost two
years in advance
um i order the fanciest colors so i kind
of pay a little extra for that like
twenty thousand dollars usually for an
extra color on a car um but i don't spec
them with a lot of carbon
carbon's the death of an exotic car you
know that's where you go
crazy hundred thousand dollars in
options i mean visible carbon pack on a
ferrari could be 40 grand right it's
crazy so i get them bare bones but
really cool looking so they're about 275
000 bucks
and we'll rent that car
per day for eighteen hundred dollars
after tax
which tax in nevada is like almost
thirty percent for car rental why is it
so much we have the highest tax in the
whole country we actually have the
highest hotel tax we basically have the
highest tourism taxes but that pays for
basically the
no other state income tax so they they
tax people almost essentially yeah we
have no state income taxes and you know
as an individual but they get all their
money from the marijuana and the rental
cars and everything so
we get about 1200 bucks from that right
so you have all those taxes and fees and
stuff that we don't get right we get
1200 the average person drives about 140
miles in that 24-hour period
so we're getting essentially
seven to eight dollars a mile
so my goal is to make about 75 000
per 10 000 miles
that's my goal
right and so if i can do that
we can pay off not pay off but pay down
and you know whatever you see as the
investment that car 10 000 miles is two
and a half months
so in seven to eight months we get our
initial money back
right and if the car can go one year
which typically it does right
um we're able to get you know a profit
from that and then we get to sell the
car for whatever's left
since the pandemic it doesn't really
play out that way because i'm not able
to get so many cars so getting cars
right now from a dealer is kind of a
luxury
so we're keeping them kind of shorter
right so we can kind of mitigate the
huge miles yeah but you know essentially
you're making about double what you pay
for the car every 12 months
you know what's the least profitable car
mclaren
why because they break every day um
and i keep at mclaren for like three
thousand miles
i can't keep them really if it hits like
2 500 i'm already starting to sell it so
i buy them brand new i'll rent them for
like one the mclarens drive less than
lamborghinis
like a lot less like
50 percent less so when someone has a
mclaren they typically don't drive it
because they're less comfortable
they're not uncomfortable yeah but
they're just not as comfortable as
something like that
so they'll drive them about 75 to 80
miles they'll do like from the strip to
red rock and back
whereas someone in a lamborghini will go
from the strip to red rock to hoover dam
and back
right so they'll do a little extra
um but those cars break too much and so
we lose them for quite a bit but before
we get into that i want to thank our
sponsor ladder so as you guys may know
i'm recently married and that got me
thinking about how truly important
family is to me and with that in mind i
now understand why people get life
insurance especially term coverage and
with how affordable it really is it
doesn't make sense not to have it like a
healthy 35 year old man can get a
million dollars of coverage for just 35
a month a price well worth such a
financial cushion and if you agree
choose ladder before ladder you would
waste so much time going to a place in
person just to find out weeks later that
you might not even be approved and if
you're like me and you don't want to
leave the house ever for any reason
ladders fast and easy application
process has got you covered with ladder
you can get fast and affordable life
insurance from the comfort of your own
home you can sign up from your phone or
laptop in just a few minutes and ladder
smart algorithms will let you know
instantly if you're approved plus
there's no hidden fees and you could
cancel anytime you want not to mention
if you change your mind in the first 30
days you'll get a full refund and life
insurance only gets pricier as you age
so now's that perfect time to cross it
off the list so go to ladderlife.com
ice coffee today that's
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee thank you so much ladder for
sponsoring this episode and with that
said let's get back to the episode smash
the like button subscribe i think it
would be interesting because you're so
young and very successful how did you
get to be so successful at a young age
when did you start this and how like
what did you have that made you so
successful in this year how old are you
i don't know how old you are i'm 33 so
i'm super old really yeah i mean um i
might look 21
yeah right uh but yeah i started when i
was 25 or 26. um
i was a cable guy and i was traveling
all over the united states doing like
strike work and hurricanes and i was
making a few thousand bucks a week it
was good i had a gtr nissan gtr it was
like i had a car payment it was like 600
bucks a month
and uh i was in town in between the
traveling jobs and i got hit by a hummer
h2 while i was driving how little mini
cooper john cooper works and i got rear
ended and i broke my back and i wasn't
able to go and i had to carry this big
28 foot ladder uh as a cable guy and i
wasn't able to do that anymore so i was
trying to find another job and in the
meantime i thought well i have this
really cool sports car if i give it to a
car rental company they'll make enough
money to pay me the payment right so i
went there was like six or seven car
rental companies in vegas at the time
it's like 2015. yeah every single person
said no they were like why would we run
a nissan and i was like i was trying to
explain this card how cool it was to
these old men that had these 355
ferraris and just this weird vibe right
and i couldn't really wrap my head
around it i was like wow this is the
exotic car rental industry in vegas
everybody was so pessimistic
so i'm driving down las vegas boulevard
and i see another gtr on the side of the
road and a guy has drive me for 99 and
i'm like oh yes this guy gets it i've
seen those cars sparked on the strip
yeah yep they they were in the
windshield always drive me 99 bucks so
he had they had a yellow guy arter there
all the time that was actually my car no
really yeah so we'll get to that part
okay but uh
so that space that you're referring to
they had at least a month or two weeks
before i had met them it's a couple of
israeli guys so i went to them and i
said hey like
can you guys buy my car because at this
point i was like kind of
beaten down everybody said no i was like
no one's gonna rent my car but maybe
they'll buy it now they already had a
white gtr and mine was red so i go to
them they said no i don't want to buy
your car i don't like red i'm like oh my
god again with these people you know
so they uh said and agreed
to let me stand next to their white one
and after their white one got rented i
was allowed to rent my red one but i had
to do all the work
and then i would give them 50 percent of
the profit
and me being like 25 26 i'm like that's
a great idea
it's on las vegas boulevard so anyways a
little bit longer story short i go out
there and i start renting my gtr and i'm
sitting in the back seat while i let
people drive the car in like a little
pre-determined route for 150
i raised the price a little bit because
my gtr was all modified at 800
horsepower so it was a cooler experience
that's right someone else no but i was
so young
i had no clue what i was doing
right so for me i would sit in the back
seat i would be nauseous all day i was
taking about 10 of those dramamine pills
and they weren't making a dent so after
two weeks i said oh i can't do this
anymore
i let my first guy from boston okay i'll
never forget this guy
take the car for six hundred dollars by
himself to red rock and back for two
hours
he went up there he went and did some
donuts in the rocks and sprayed the side
of my car with a bunch of rocks
the first rental i ever did
this happened
and i'm just sitting here like oh my
gosh what did i do i made a huge mistake
but i don't want to go with these people
i don't want to sit in the back seat
and so i just kept now my car was messed
up yeah had sprayed rocks all over it
the guy dumped it he didn't pay me it
was a big huge mess and i felt okay
whatever i'm in it now so i just started
letting everybody take the car i just
crossed my fingers it would come back
and uh six months later i had like eight
cars
so i had the yellow gallardo yeah i had
a white r8 um i had a red california um
i had a
whole bunch of slingshots yeah and then
i had a bunch of scooters no i'm curious
how were you able to get financing for
these guys to begin with because getting
the gtr obviously you had a good job
you're making a few thousand dollars a
week so how much were you making a month
when you got the gtr um well when i was
renting those cars right oh well when
you bought it when i bought the gtr i
was making like 18 000 a month gross wow
but it was all piece work so i wouldn't
make it consistently yeah so you only
make that money when you were working so
you would get a job for three months
make you know fifty thousand dollars and
then you'd be out of work until the next
strike or the next hurricane so you'd go
into work at like a 1500 a week pace and
then when those big jobs happen you get
like 5 000 a week wow so it was okay
but um but how are you able to get
financing on these cards because even
for me uh i when i looked into this a
few years ago and it was so difficult i
wanted
it was a brief moment where i wanted a
gallardo superleggera
brief moment very nice car and uh even
speaking of the banks it's just like
they wanted you to have a history of
working your way up and since i had
always paid cash for these cars i had
never had a previous loan they were like
well we want you to have a mid tier and
see don't just go from nothing to this
car so what you're talking about
happened to me when i went from the gtr
to the gallardo okay and so i bought the
2006 gallardo spider and it was a
hundred and sixteen thousand dollars
um i had only had a loan on my gtr which
the gtr i bought for i believe it was
like low 70s it was a 2015
and um they were they were giving like
twenty thousand dollars off msrp back
then there were gtrs or 106 000 bucks
they were really hard to sell and this
one was a demo so it had miles on it so
i think i was out the door just about 80
grand and i put 10 000 down right so the
down payment is the most important part
of financing a car right i mean there's
a lot of guys on the internet that'll
tell you zero down there zero down that
i mean it's
i don't get that that no one does those
loans
in the car business if you put thirty
percent down you're automatically
approved no matter what you could tell
them you make a bajillion dollars a year
and they won't check it if you put 30
down it's like the golden rule for
financing cars okay so when i when i got
the gallardo um i already had the gtr
and i didn't really want to trade it in
i wanted to keep it right because i was
kind of like well this car is making
money i don't want to sell that one just
to get a different one to make a little
more money i want to make a lot more
money and have two
so i i saved for those those months that
we were making money i had two months
that we were making money and i saved
forty thousand dollars from the rental
fees right and so i was able to put
forty thousand dollars down and i
financed it with a company called putnam
leasing which is like a twenty percent
interest crappy
but
when i was that age and i was making
money from the car i didn't really
matter to me
and so
they don't put it on your credit report
they don't uh
really write it down unless you do like
a bad deal with them it's it's often
it's under the table it's a leasing
company and most exotic car financing is
like that
so two months after that i was able to
go to another leasing company and put 40
000 down in the ferrari california
which also did not report to my credit
report so all i had was this gtr on my
credit that was with the regular bank
yeah and so now i had three cars and
those three cars were making enough
money for me to buy fourth car cash and
that was a mclaren mp4 12c
so by the time i had four cars
it was a lot of money coming in right
but then there was a lot of money going
out and so essentially
after about six months i had a lot of
things i had scooters i had slingshots i
had all this stuff had a bunch of car
payments
and the city came down and uh
sent these two guys a letter
and basically they were doing business
on a business license
well they kind of had a business license
but it was at a location like a
warehouse on the side of the strip
somewhere and they were doing business
in the front
so
i was like kind of like completely
shocked
and they shut us down
i had all this
debt i had all these cars i had 35 40
scooters that i was renting and i had
nowhere to go
and these guys just kind of packed up
and were like sorry
i was like what
and i was i panicked i had no idea i
went home i like started crying i was
like i told my wife i sold my house
for us to expand this like little
business right i had had to buy some you
know time money to pay my bills because
all that money wasn't going to pay my
bills i was going to pay like for cars
so i sold my house about a month before
this happened and my wife almost killed
me i'm pretty sure that she wanted to
so uh i
used the last fifteen thousand dollars i
had and i leased the space that you went
to
wow i
didn't did any at any point it crossed
your mind it's like well you know i
could sell off these cars i built up
some equity in them yeah but then i
would have to be a cable guy again and i
already had this cool lifestyle where i
mean after you buy a really nice car i
don't really care what it is
it's old and you want another one after
a couple weeks right like there's always
another one there's always a better one
so after i had gotten
three really cool supercars and i still
had the gtr and then i had a slingshot i
had all these things and
my family saw like how i was doing so
good and yeah i was really innovative i
mean no one had really kind of done this
before hourly supercar rentals right it
was a it was a new thing
so i didn't want to let anybody down and
i really didn't want to show any
weakness so no one actually knew besides
my wife yeah that the business wasn't
like cool
and i was kind of young and dumb and so
when i went i leased this space
at dean martin the one you went to and i
just put up a sign out front and people
from the bellagio could see the sign and
they called the day i opened i mean i
went through the licensing process and
yeah i got all my stuff situated right
and that took about 45 days right so
through that time leasing it getting all
of it ready i went down to zero dollars
like nothing like my credit cards are
maxed out i had no money and the only
way i was going to survive if i had rent
rented those cars
and the first day we opened i did
and so kind of like the rest is history
yeah and when you were working with
those two guys using their lot were they
just making bank off of you if you were
still giving them 50 of what you're
making at that point wouldn't you have
realized that it would probably be
better if you were to get your own lot
if you're paying them half of your so i
wasn't only just paying them half i was
actually paying them fees as well they
were charging me for insurance
which there definitely wasn't insurance
right i mean they they keep telling me
to this day i mean i'm not to this day
a few years ago i ran into one of the
guys i'm like dude just tell me the
truth was it really insurance because it
was like ten thousand dollars a month
now i'm just sitting here like
was there really insurance
and he swears to this day there was a
church i was curious how that worked
it's how the intro like if a car was
wrecked did you so you didn't have
insurance in your name in that car at
that time all those cars are registered
to my personal name oh wow and they were
all personally insured by me which if
you were to have rented the car
i would have been screwed if you would
have crashed it because i wasn't i
didn't have my stuff together yet yeah
like i didn't know what i was doing
right and i didn't understand rental
contracts but when i was forced to do
this on my own and i had no one else i
had to learn i went to the dmv i got my
license to sell insurance i became an
insurance broker insurance agent i got
my license to do every single thing car
sales car dealer so i went through the
state stuff and i i mean i'm actually
like
pretty interested in learning the law
and the to do it the right way so i
spent a lot of time reading all the
manuals and the books for the dmv and
everything and so through this process i
actually became
relatively smarter you know i mean it
was a it was a good learning experience
and now that's why royalty still exists
the typical age of an exotic carbon
company is like a year and a half to two
years why because they don't do all of
the things the right way they did it how
i did it in the beginning where there's
no insurance and you had all your cars
financed now there's no royalty cards
financed i mean there hasn't been for
years but
in the beginning you know i wasn't
wealthy i didn't have any money for my
parents i didn't have anything so i just
did it the way i could and i got away
with it but today you can't do that
anymore i mean
now there's like so many players like
turo and all these other apps and ride
share things and this and that it's
really easy for people to just put up
one car in one of those apps and make a
little bit of money right to do what i
do to start and to get to the 50 car
level it takes a massive overhead and i
mean five years of youtube videos it's a
lot of work yeah why don't you do touro
why not put a few of the cars up there
and just kind of capture that market as
well
because i have more customers than touro
now okay um i have a wider range
actually touro like four years ago
reached out to us and invited us we put
some slingshots on touro and like the
first customer crashed it like that
wrecked it but like destroyed it like
the front hit the curb and everything
and turo said because we were a
commercial business that
we're on our own we just pay for it and
i was like well that's not okay like
doesn't the customer have insurance or
something so we had like a really bad
experience but they take 30
and sometimes up to 50
so if i have my own network of people
you know we have our own business then
why would we want to give it away for no
reason that's like paying google ads or
you know some advertising service right
and plus touro is actually kind of a bad
business they don't really price match
or price cap different categories
so
if you have a slingshot and yours is 500
mine could be five dollars
it could be 20 it could be 100
we can set our own prices and that's
kind of unfair to the renter because if
there's like 10 of the same car
the lowest one wins right and it works
from the bottom up and the guy that
actually knows what the value of his car
is really never rents the car
so it's kind of unfair turo should
change their business model slightly i
think it's kind of similar to airbnb
though where people could set their own
rates and you know you want to stay
competitive but at the same time you
want to try to maximize yeah
right it's not like you're renting the
exact same thing that's true yeah so
like if i'm looking for a lamborghini
huracan and i have one for or you have
one for 1 000
and he has one for 500
well who do you think i'm gonna rent
it's the same thing
right so the same condo isn't the same
condo you know i mean it's like a little
bit unique and airbnb is actually
relatively competitive i mean they're
all pretty much the same you know i
think in the car world because people
have different car payments they have
different insurance payments the variety
of people that have them right in their
current living situation dictate the
price that the cars get rented for got
it right if someone wants to make 500 a
month or five thousand dollars a month
that determines your price point
that's interesting how much are you
making now from the entire rental car
business just overall because i'm
curious about if you if you're
comfortable sharing some of that sure
yeah the number is behind it it depends
with covid we did really good and then
we did really bad we did really good and
we did really bad right so we don't
really know where we're gonna sit but
typically with the fleet size that i
have it should be six to eight million
dollar a year revenue business right
that should be adequate
um we've done better than that and we've
done worse than that you know so it kind
of fluctuates right now quite a bit yeah
but then it's also the overhead right so
then you have
leasing space insurance
uh what about like gasoline or repairs
how often do these cars need to be
repaired
damages or damages are prevalent right
damages happen every day um i actually
started making my own wheels
like i manufacture my own wheels now
because they were damaging so many
wheels and lamborghini and ferrari were
unable they don't make that many wheels
like they don't have them in stock so
like curbed wheels happen
sometimes three to four times a day and
sometimes they crack and like i'm kind
of against powder coating because i'm
like a firm believer if you powder coat
your wheel too many times it weakens the
integrity of it and i don't really like
to take risk like i don't leave myself
open for anybody to sue me
so uh we make our own wheels now that's
how many damaged wheels we get so i've
got like a warehouse full of 600 sets of
wheels that wow are ready to go at any
given time to replace on a car
um i stock like almost every bumper uh
every brake pad
the the way you make money in car
rentals is to never have the car
unavailable
right and if you come and rent the car
and you get a flat tire
it may be your fault but you're going to
want your money back so like i have a
van specifically dedicated with the tire
machine and everything built in i can
drive to you and change your tire right
there because i'm really i don't like
giving people their money back for
things that i can control right so the
car rental business is very
demanding for extreme immediate service
right and when someone feels like they
get that service you get the amazing
customer and you get very loyal people
that want to rent
10 20 30 times
and when you're renting a car at the
price point that we rent yeah that's a
great customer
right and that comes down to service so
the
typical person rents one time
but like right now we're seeing like a
30 to 35 percent repeat rate because of
the pandemic because there's not that
many things to do people are coming back
to vegas a lot right i mean if you live
in southern california there's more
restrictions there than there are here
right and if you live in other states
like the east coast there's also more
restrictions there so they come here
more often
because they're not going to europe or
wherever so
right now it's okay
do you think your average customer is
someone that's just trying to rent a car
for a day and have a good time or would
you say that they're like because in my
opinion just from someone who doesn't
know much about the business i feel like
a lot of people would want to rent a car
to like show off you're going back to
your high school reunion or you're
taking a girl on a date something like
that oh jack you should you should get a
car to pick up a date we gotta go yeah
let's do that no we could vlog it
picking up a date and a lamborghini
hurricane i i i i could not actually do
that why not jack that is so
embarrassing you have to do it that is
so horribly embarrassing not in paris i
would not get a second date yes you
would i guarantee you would make a
difference listen you would get a second
date but not a third date because when
you showed up in your regular car on the
second day oh right yeah then she'd be
like what's this
yeah yes bait and switch yeah second
date guaranteed third date probably not
got it well i drive a lexus too okay
well that's good 2005 rx 330. it's all
the same lexus is lexus right yeah
exactly so a very similar car yeah very
very similar you probably have better
seats than i do mine are relatively
uncomfortable i got seat warmers i don't
know if you i don't he drives a lexus
lfa
i drove that today yes yeah the uh the
customers come in are like 99
today
about showing off right there's like one
percent that people come in and they
rent cars for longer than one day where
they're
used to that car and they own those cars
where they're from and they want that
car while they're on vacation right
that's like one percent of people it's
crazy to me to be like that's my
threshold i need that car everywhere i
go yeah i mean it's
it's tough because like you're the
typical rental car person when they come
to las vegas vegas is such an easy place
to use that car
do you rent that car when you're in
dallas texas for business probably not
right do you rent that car when you're
in miami yeah like it's easy to show off
in miami just as easy to show off on las
vegas boulevard right and actually las
vegas has a lot of cool places to drive
and use the cars i mean you live in a
wonderful place right i mean there's
great roads out here they're open
they're clean it's all paved right so
it's a good place to use the car too so
i think we have pretty much a millennial
focused business right now that is a lot
centered around instagram and people
showing off but that's also a bad thing
because when people show off they make
poor choices i'm curious
i i remember seeing on instagram where
people were renting out the private jets
on the inside just to take pictures and
videos
why haven't you done that with cars of
just like people could go and take
pictures with the car the car stays
stationary but you could have a cool
backdrop or something and i mean maybe
we could rent a car to like selfie world
right where that's where they do that
sure they they have sets
built out that are for people to take
selfies and show off right
um
i don't know i think i'm kind of like
trying to focus on the more
i want to say bigger money but
i mean how much could how much would you
pay to take a picture in a lamborghini
twenty dollars right maybe yeah
a lamborghini seed is fourteen thousand
dollars so how many people will take to
ruin the seat so you would need 700
you'd need 700 people to make that money
back
just to break even and replace your seat
i don't know it doesn't seem like you're
not good for business that's fair
it's wild to me because i do see anytime
you're on the strip the people it and
you always know they're the rentals
because they're completely stock they're
bone stock cars usually
no tints and they're bright colors
always and uh the windows are always
down
and uh the music's all the way up and
they're always look they're looking
around always looking and they're
looking at people and they're like oh
they're looking at me they're looking at
me it's kind of funny they're looking
yeah and uh you can tell because they're
always leaving first gear open till the
end oh yeah
yeah so downshifting a little too early
i kind of pride myself in window tint
and black wheels
and uh i'm uh one of the founders of
rift exhaust so like i try to put
exhaust on the cars and make them a
little bit more than the typical rental
that you would see from another company
yeah right like i'm really offended by
people that have silver wheels on their
car i mean silver works on some cars but
like on a orange lamborghini i feel like
it just should have aggressive black
wheels and look more like it's your own
yeah right so it's uh that's kind of
like a little bit more royalty has that
ownership look yeah there's no like
license plates that say rental on them
or rent me or phone numbers so that's
always been kind of a staple of our
business
that's interesting what's shocking to me
is the fact that you can start a
multi-million dollar business or at
least a business that grosses over a
thousand dollars a day with just like
thirty to forty thousand dollars
i mean i think that's most good
businesses
i mean i started uh a restaurant with
not forty thousand dollars but i started
a restaurant with like 200 000 and it
it's already got we've already got 10
locations right let's talk about that
why did you decide to do a restaurant
isn't that a business that so many
people fail at is that a really
difficult thing to get into you know i
swear i don't know why but when people
tell me that the number one failing
businesses are the ones you obviously
don't do it makes me want to do those
only i don't know why it's like crazy to
me but yeah like the restaurant was
always a big thing and i've always
wanted to be in the quick service
industry because i feel like the
customer
i guess once you
once you have the experience with a
customer that spends two thousand
dollars with you and the level of detail
you have to have
everything seems easy right the level of
responsibility when i give you a four
hundred thousand dollar car and you give
me two thousand dollars and there's no
other money exchanged there's no deposit
there's nothing else
it's a very large risk and you have to
be really focused on who you're giving
that to otherwise you can end up on a
youtube video right yeah because that's
pretty much the customers that that get
there the ones that probably shouldn't
be doing that
and when you learn that customer and you
learn that type of business you learn
so much about people
and the control you have within that
atmosphere so like for the restaurant
industry for me to give you a sandwich
for twelve dollars
it seems like like the child's plate to
me like i'm like it's so easy
you're either gonna ask me for twelve
dollars back because you didn't like it
or you're gonna eat it and love it
or maybe you eat it and give me a
three-star review there's like three
options there sure yeah you're not gonna
take the sandwich and hit me in the face
with it you're not gonna steal it right
and take it to california and it's gonna
get impounded somewhere and i'm not
gonna be able to get it back right and
you're not going to like go and do crazy
things and risk everybody's life and i
have to file insurance claim to get my
sandwich back right so all of those
crazy things that happen at royalty
can't happen in a restaurant so all i
have to do with the restaurant to be
successful is to give you that same
feeling you get when you get that two
thousand dollar lamborghini
not what makes it easier it was two
hundred thousand dollars to start this
up
basically yeah i mean we've spent more
money since then because we have nine
locations now but the first restaurant
um we spent a little over two hundred
thousand dollars at um we've made
improvements after we opened but we got
voted the number one restaurant in las
vegas on yelp for 2021
and that restaurant grosses almost as
much as our chicken as our uh royalty
exotic cars no eight million six to
eight million dollars in one restaurant
uh well we have two now okay that are
open open yeah we'll have we have eight
under construction two are open each
restaurant's doing about 250 000 a month
wow out of 2 000 square feet what's the
overhead like because i've seen on
restaurants it's like a 10 to 15 profit
margin is that about accurate 25 to 28
for what we do because we have one item
we have chicken fried chicken so we have
a 84 sku restaurant yeah so uh we are
just starting to sell franchises in
january right now
but uh the hot chicken industry is like
blowing up like crazy so
we're getting uh average about 7 500 to
10 000 a day in revenue which is
essentially 700 customers a day in a 2
000 square foot space at an average uh
average ticket at 21
so it's like really really really good
business how do you get so many people
i mean youtube helps a lot yeah right
because we're popular is it the channel
um your channel or is it is there
another like houston's chicken no
there's only um
behind the scenes of that so that would
be great yeah we're my business partner
edmund he um uh his youtube channel was
edmund monday i think uh armandi and
he's uh he was a professional race car
driver so since
i have royalty and i'm like full-fledged
in my rental car business i put like 50
of my time in the business but he's a
hundred percent there so he is vowed to
change his youtube channel to basically
the houston's hot chicken youtube
channel where i mean we have like some
of the hottest chicken tenders in
america so like we have like this game
called tender roulette where there's
like six tenders and everybody grabs one
and some have no spice and some have the
you don't want to taste that spice
because it could kill you right and so
we have all these like games that we
play and that's what his channel is
going to turn into so the tender
roulette i mean the tender eating
competition how many people can eat the
spiciest stuff it's really fun to watch
like that stuff right there for me is
exciting it's funny i think this is pure
coincidence but uh i don't know if you
know this guy on tick tock uh he goes
hooked l i think it's hooked lv yeah
he's a big he actually uh runs our
social media are you serious yeah well i
mean he's awesome yeah he helps us um
run our social media so his video came
up now i'm uh i'm i have i have two tick
tock accounts one of them is my my
personal one where i where i watch them
the other one is just a random one that
uh just for you know random scrolling or
whatever but uh
his video came up on houston's chicken
yeah and it was so good and he actually
reached out to me uh as just a
subscriber when when we moved to vegas
and we met up with him yeah he's such a
smart guy yeah i met him when i first
first started the idea of opening this
restaurant this is early 2019
and um
he was working at whole foods yeah uh
and i met him there and he was talking
showing me his vlog or his uh uh account
his tech talk yeah and how he does
restaurant reviews and i'm like man like
when we open you're gonna be my guy yeah
so we had talked to him first i mean i
had seen him at whole foods he was
working at like the little deli thing
i've seen him for like a year before you
know we shut down and everything i was
going to the grocery store all the time
and i would always say hi to him we chat
and talk and so when we opened he was my
guy he was the guy that helped us so uh
we gave him the contract to do our
social media yeah and he's great and he
actually has a lot of really good ideas
too and i'm hoping he has a really cool
burger place i want to invest in but
that's maybe for the future yeah that's
cool yeah i'm thinking this would be so
viral to be able to do like that you
know the hottest chicken ever little
challenges like that i think i mean
there's so much content you can make
with food because it reaches such a wide
audience that's like what the car
business is tough because it reaches car
guys and i like i mean we're mutual
friends with strideman right and i talk
to james every once in a while when i go
up to utah and i'm just like you know
james like what's next i always ask him
and he never really gives me a straight
answer but what's next for him yeah
because i mean how many more subscribers
can he get right i mean he's been doing
it though which is crazy i love it for
the last year of like what else could he
do
but he keeps delivering on just great
content it's wild and so like once you
take get out of that niche of like one
specific thing right food is like a
completely open genre that reaches the
world's population because everybody
eats everybody wants to you know we
release all those really great um
uh what's the word i'm looking for but
uh like the serotonin in your brain when
you eat something really good right
people crave it i mean that's why we're
all over overweight right i mean that's
why i'm overweight because when i'm
stressed out i'd love to go eat
something good i'm trying to lose that
yeah that's my resolution this year yeah
is it really yeah i've made my
resolution to never want to lose my
weight because like it's just something
i always try to do and i just can't so i
just accepted the fact that i'm just
gonna eat good
you know i'm gonna eat healthy i don't
know i think i think there's a balance
like i'm hungry right now and i'm
resisting i'm starving right really i'm
so hungry see now we're doing the
chicken and i was like geez that would
be yeah you can make me so hungry it's
dinner time we could have sponsored this
episode it just brought in some chicken
and oh my god we couldn't we should have
had i didn't think about it we should
have had one of our we get like four or
five burgers and one of them should be
the really hot one and we all agree that
we have to eat that one i'm vegetarian
vegetarian
if you are oh
for 30 days i can make you a houston so
houston we have a problem is our hottest
sandwich naturally great name right and
so liftoff is the one right before it
and then you have spicy medium mild and
then we have a
memphis dr memphis dry rub and then we
have one that has no spice at all just
chicken for kids grams and
you know stuff for me the memphis dry
rub is kind of like my favorite cause i
try i have a pretty weak stomach myself
so i try not to eat anything spicy so
that memphis one's pretty good but uh
houston we have a problem we could make
it a tofu
so you can do a fried tofu for you
and uh it'll it's actually not bad the
tofu was good first time ever tried tofu
i mean we fried it and put all the
seasoning on it so kind of tasted like
chicken to me but one thing i thought
that you did that i really liked a lot
didn't you host a car meet yesterday
yes going back to that
we do car meets once a month and we
bring i mean we had four or five
thousand the f-spot video was out of
houston's hot chicken car me yeah it's
like four or five thousand yeah yeah you
invited me that night it was at night
right yeah yeah yeah i couldn't make it
i wanted to make it though yeah it's uh
we do them once a month and so for every
grand opening we have a few grand
openings coming up we have two in april
and then we're opening our fashion show
mall location on the strip uh probably
in june so that one's gonna be hard to
do a car show because it's inside you
know the mall on las vegas boulevard but
for every new place we have two
drive-throughs that are opening in uh in
march april may whatever those are and
those are gonna be really fun because uh
we're gonna have cars all over the place
and there's those are great shows so
i've had this uh
this theory okay and i've had two
friends in the past who have opened
restaurants we've always said when you
open a restaurant you have to have a car
meet in the parking lot
and
both people who didn't do it the
businesses did not end up doing well so
from now on i'm like in order for a
business to do well they have to do a
car meeting in the park it works though
because you get so many people just
parking there out front of the place you
get cool cars there everyone's like oh
what are they what's going on oh it's
the houston's car meet something so we
have
i think we have like
we have 410 five-star reviews we have
seven one stars
and about four of our one stars
are because people were mad about our
car meet it was too loud it went on too
late it was all the old grand oh it's
great i love it yeah if i can get a one
star review that talks bad about how
many people came to my restaurant i
think i'm doing something good right and
the other three bad ones are because
it's too hot right i mean one guy walked
in and was like i need your hottest
sandwich right now and then he said in
the review that he has a sensitivity to
spice i'm just like you know
were you on drugs when are you doing
this like i don't feel like you should
order the hottest yeah there's 2 million
scoville units 2 million i don't know
what that means yeah a normal mild
popeye spicy sandwich right like yeah
that's pop by spice sandwich it's so
good 25 000 squibble units
25 000 to 2 million that's the
how is that difference though it's not
that no one's supposed to eat it that's
why it's called houston we have a
problem you shouldn't eat that one
you're like you haven't [ __ ] i can i
can't even smell it i'm like never had
it no oh my gosh
i haven't even eaten the medium one i'm
scared
i'm i'm like not about spice you know
so
would you eat a gram
i don't i hate i hate hot but if we had
a competition you and i loser had to eat
it
i don't know if i'd be able to finish it
i would try it so the sandwich
is is kind of a cheater way to try it
because you have coleslaw you have
pickles you have our sauce you have the
bread
the real way to screw someone up is to
let them eat the tenders
the tenders are plain it's just spice on
spice on spice
there's nothing else just more spicy
somebody finished the whole thing yes
one of my employees
andre
is
he he must not have any taste buds he
could eat this houston we have a problem
tender with a blank face and just eat it
he doesn't even make an expression his
body is sweating you can see him
physically sweating but like we've had
people
take one bite and profusely puke we've
had people pass out
like you have to sign a waiver like you
have to wave like you're like
legitimately you could go to the
hospital
if you eat too much of these particular
spices and so like it's dangerous i mean
you're not supposed to eat scorpion
powder or pepper you're not supposed to
eat these things and so like people this
is like a challenge right i mean the hot
chicken genre the space
is kind of fitted with these people
trying too spicy of things now some
people can handle it no problem i mean
if you're from some ethnic regions that
are used to those spices when you grow
up obviously you're going to be okay
but coming from las vegas where i've
never even seen a ghost pepper or i mean
let alone a habanero in some places
that's like insane to me you know
so it's pretty
it's pretty dangerous
do you ever turn anybody down at the
restaurant all the time
really this lady wanted her
eight-year-old son
she signed a waiver for eight year old
son i said ma'am listen
you can write me all the reviews you
want but you're not taking this and
you're not giving this to your kid and
that was that and i happened to be there
at that moment i don't know maybe she
didn't like him i'm not sure it's the
only excuse i can think about she just
didn't unders stan maybe her son wanted
it she didn't get i i really have no
idea but like if you just understand i
mean we literally label scoville units
right
like hot cheetos right are like five
thousand scoville units really they're
no no those are hotter than popeye's hot
chicks they're yeah
yeah well it's but when you eat popeye's
chicken you have so much more to
you're eating like such a different way
like if you just take popeye's chicken
and cut it up and eat it it's going to
be way spicier than if you have it with
bread and all the sauce right because it
drowns it out so you have to look up
scoville units and do your research
before you like go there and go crazy
that's fair maybe i'm just a skeptic
because i've never really had anything
that's like that hot like i had the
world's sourest candy but that was how
we did that that was still very tolerant
oh my god
i can't even eat a warhead yeah i think
we still do
yeah i mean
yeah no that's that's fair but even the
world's sourest candy was on that chip
no it's not no that's supposed to be
crazy hot uh but it's different it's
like a it's a very it's a dark ghost
pepper that they use and it's a very
hard ghost pepper and i heard that
there's scorpion pepper on it too
scorpion pepper is like very very harsh
right like different peppers do
different things right i mean you've
eaten wasabi at a sushi restaurant right
that's only spicy in your mouth and then
like it kind of goes away right but
there's peppers that don't go away they
like increase the more you digest it
right and so that's kind of the the one
chip challenge where you eat it and
you're like okay and then it like
destroys you it's like an explosion and
you can watch some of these people i
mean i watch shaq eat it
it's pretty funny
i'm sure for him the chip is like this
big it was like this
i've seen this video it keeps getting
recommended of shaq with the water
bottle yeah i see normal people there
so the water bottle looks like this and
he's just holding it
that's hilarious yeah it's it's really
interesting it's very interesting what
uh
uh
where
influencer culture is building now right
i mean think about all the
things that we think are cool today and
so that's why houston's hot chicken
works you know if i open like a thai
restaurant
i might not do good you know who knows
yeah now you turn down people at the
restaurant occasionally for certain
situations like that what about the the
car rental business somebody walked in
and you're just like no i could i could
tell that
i am the king of turndowns
yeah
like the king how do you do that in a
way that they don't feel like i have
like no feelings anymore really i am i
it doesn't matter i used to be like
i would just make them jump through more
hoops get better insurance and do this
and do that now i'm just like here's an
address of a company that will rent to
you that feels more comfortable with it
that's what i said yeah and what sort of
red flags do you look for today in
during the pandemic era it's mostly
uh younger kids right
i don't know why but we never really had
like the 18 to 21 year olds
yeah we make it pretty mandatory to do
25 but like you don't always know when
they're not 25 until you like go through
the whole process you've rented them the
car then you get their id like we don't
get their id and check their insurance
first before they pay typically they pay
online they preserve it and then we find
we see them then we see their id
so it becomes a little bit more
difficult to turn them away once you've
already have a reservation a month in
advance and all of those factors right
we get their insurance about a week
before they rent typically so we can
kind of mitigate some of that but
sometimes people don't send their
insurance something that on on your
website that says like you must be over
25 and like they they certify and yeah
they don't listen to that that happens
all the time yeah so if so let's say i
walked into your place and i wanted to
rent a car would do you think i would be
approved or denied jackson 23. well he's
23.
i already can tell you it's approved
right
there's certain mannerisms that you can
tell someone's responsible or not
responsible
right and uh i mean i can tell by your
hairstyle that you're responsible like
it's my hair is excruciating
thank you
he's pretty bad yeah you're not you're
not impressing anybody yeah i mean
there's just certain i mean how do you
explain this without being offensive
right you can't but like you just learn
how to read people and what
they're feeling right like their vibe
their aura like all that stuff really
plays into a factor how calm they are
how they talk right if they come in with
a group of like 10 guys
and they want one car it's an automatic
zero no for me that was what we uh it
was lucky who helped us get uh for
father's day we got a lambo and a
ferrari we brought it back and uh
that exact same situation it was like it
must they almost have been 20 21 years
old five of them all wanting to rent one
car and it seemed as though they were
each like throwing in like a little bit
each like a hundred bucks each yeah and
they're just gonna share it
that's a hard no for me yeah um anybody
that comes in
with like any girls that come in that
seem like they should be renting a car a
lot of guys with no insurance will send
their girlfriends in and rent cars like
straw renters happens every day
and it's typically like on holiday
weekends right it doesn't happen like on
a regular weekend where it's like
families or the events are different
it's like memorial day or super bowl
weekend where you get like a large crowd
from like
all over the world or all over the
country and uh you can kind of tell like
they're more they're nervous you know or
they're they have like kind of like
they're on the phone a lot
there's a lot of those little red flags
that you're just like we can't rent you
you know because a lot of people uh it
happened actually to another car rental
company of mine it's kind of a sad story
yeah
but a girl walked in rented the car
and her uninsured
unlicensed boyfriend was driving like
over 150 miles an hour and hit someone
else on a motorcycle and that motorcycle
list died no and so
those things typically happen and i'm
like a really big proponent of this like
i'm in like the news and i'm working
with the city to try to change this
because
it's really dangerous and there's really
no regulation in this industry a lot of
people risk a lot of things and so
um a lot of companies don't really go
through and check their renters right
and they uh i do a pretty deep check
like i have like a physical driver's
license scanner we get like a dmv record
like it's pretty quick i mean we have to
pay seven bucks for it but it helps us
make those determinations you know so
there was another accident that happened
with a guy who had just got out of jail
for a dui it was his third or second dui
wow three hours later he was or not
three or it was like a little bit later
a few hours later he was driving like
140 miles an hour down tropicana lost
control and had a gun on the sidewalk
first third dui
so
those types of things you gotta avoid
i've never
knock on wood had any injury accidents
since i've started but i'm really picky
because like there's always another
customer that's responsible i think four
million people come to vegas every month
if i only have 80 cars
it's pretty good odds i'm gonna rent
them every day right i mean and if you
have less than 80 cars like let's say 10
12 right most of the other competitors
here down have like 10 to 12 cars
you're gonna rent them every day you
don't have to push the luck and just
take the first dollar that comes in yeah
right and so that's kind of the big red
flags you got to be very careful you
were telling us though about like going
to california and having to get like to
go to court
what happened there how common is that
so
i had a woman
rent a car and uh
she came from the cosmo she refused this
is
unfortunately while i was out of town
and uh had a couple of new employees
that were training we had a retail store
at the mall so those employees trained
at our main office then went to the mall
and sold rentals
so this one of my new girls was renting
a car didn't really learn the the red
flags yet rented a car to a girl and uh
took all the information over the phone
and went to the cosmo to drop off a
dodge hellcat and they did the contract
there on the spot took the picture did
all the stuff
but um we didn't get her in our office
and so
that was a big issue
she paid to go to california and it's
okay like sometimes international people
will come from like the uk and they'll
want to go to disneyland that happens
like every time i mean if you come from
the uk that's a cool place yeah so they
fly into vegas and then they drive to
disneyland and come back so you take an
suv or a four-seater car yeah right so
they have a fee for that and they go and
they do it they come back so this girl
paid she rented the car for three days
and um on the third day she was due back
at 2 30 like one o'clock we tracked the
car and it was still in california so we
sent her a message and she's like oh
yeah i'm so sorry i'll extend it charge
my card well her card got declined
so she's like well i'm on my way back
right now i'll just pay you guys cash i
can't put in the account just an excuse
after excuse after an excuse
so like the fourth day happened and the
car is still in the exact same spot it's
right next to dodger stadium like it's
it hasn't moved in it hasn't actually
moved in three days so on the second day
she's in california it was still there
so now it's the fifth day and she
doesn't answer us anymore we call we do
this we do that so i said okay guys i
had a location in orange county i mailed
the key there and they went up to go get
the car yeah so they go to this guy's
house or this this house where the car
is at
and the cars in the driveway they just
turn the car on they back it out they
get in the street and as this is
happening some older gentleman comes out
screaming and yelling where are you
taking my son's car
and my renter's like well he rented it
he's like no he bought this car and my
one of my employees like i'm sorry you
just were confused it's just a rental he
didn't bring it back we're gonna take it
now
he calls the police and
it turns out
that the son was actually a police
officer
and he purchased this car on offer up
he purchased my hellcat on offer up
now there's a little bit more to the
story in my opinion because
why would a police officer give
30 percent less value the car was 30
less value
on offer up
how does that in cash yeah and think
it's a legitimate transaction how did he
didn't get a title he did they made a
title for this car so they had someone
at the dmv make a title legitimate
california title
but
the title number was wrong there was a
it was a manufactured title number yeah
and the vin number was one digit off and
then the year was also wrong
so like the title wasn't like legit and
like if you checked the title on the
thing it was wrong like it was the car
was a 2017. title said 16. it was really
weird yeah and like the title looked
perfect but you had to like look into it
so these police officers come and
they're like going crazy they didn't
know what to believe and so i'm in las
vegas at the time and i'm like why
didn't i go to this one you know this
was a huge video right we were filming
the whole thing
and it turns out this woman
sold this car to this guy
i think that guy was hit on it because i
don't see who in the right mind pays 30
less in cash as a officer of the law for
a car and doesn't drive it
he the act the place where they said
that they bought it yeah it drove from
there to his house stayed there three
days
if you buy a brand new hellcat aren't
you going to every one of your moms and
friends and everybody you know is house
and showing off and doing burnout just
keeping it
there
not driving it it was at his house i
feel like he was
he was the one
in my opinion that created the title and
hadn't sold it yet
that's where i'm at because he was too
calm about losing x amount of dollars
and it was a large amount of money
like why would he
he said he paid cash but okay there was
no record got it and i'm like okay so
i'm telling you if i buy a brand new
lamborghini i'm gonna drive that thing
every second of the day i'm gonna go to
work and back and here and there in the
gas station i'm just gonna go to the
7-eleven just to get gas and i don't
need it could you ask for a bank
statement or something it's just like oh
i want to see that i mean through that
like i mean why does the police officer
have x amount of dollars in cash i mean
the hellcat's worth 60 000 you pretty
much do the math that's right right 30
less of that is what the alleged amount
was i mean
it's a little fishy
so
they impound this car because i refused
to report the car stolen
and the reason i refused to do that was
because if i report the car stolen
i'm gonna have to get my insurance
involved they're gonna have to do an
investigation i'm gonna have to file a
claim
right we go back to that insurance thing
that i was talking about and it's going
to be a huge mess and they're going to
impound the car and then it's going to
say stolen recovery on carfax
which is going to devalue the car even
more and the people who rented it didn't
have legitimate insurance likely right
weren't a legitimate person right so we
didn't find this out until after but of
course all the documents they gave us
were fake right and so all of these
things happen and the police take our
car
so they threaten me and say if you don't
report this stolen to protect our
officer
that's what he said we're going to
impound it they took the car for three
months and didn't call me they ghosted
me
every single day i'd call them and call
them and call them and then after like
three months they're like hey we called
you three months ago to pick up this car
come get it and they made the release
stamp the day after they picked it up
wow just so that i had no right to
sue the department for wrongful and
everything all that stuff they were very
calculated it was a really weird
situation it was the weirdest thing
that's ever happened to my company
period wow so why not just can't you
self-insure
i want a million dollars a year
i want to yeah i mean i think that's the
necessary next step yeah at 400 000 a
year
maybe it wasn't the right thing but now
it seems like the only logical thing to
do yeah you know so i'm i'm gonna have
to do that this year i think or we just
translate our business into something
else right i mean with youtube i thought
about becoming a full-fledged car
dealership we're licensed to do that
right i mean if we just do rentals on
the side
right then maybe it's not that big of a
deal right we don't have to have all of
our eggs in one basket you know if we
just sell cars rent them a little bit
here and there and make the main focus
something else the insurance liability
will go down dramatically right but um
self-insuring is probably the only
answer
how has the appreciation of like the
used car market affected you with such
high inventory and just the overall cost
of cars uh increasing lately i mean
that's the best thing that's happened
because i had all these cars you know 50
plus cars before the appreciation
happened
so like the entire year of 2020
most of 21
i didn't take any depreciation so what's
your thought about the value of the used
car market is it getting too crazy right
now
just to put this into perspective yeah
um i'll give you a real life example
my sister-in-law leased a 2000 whatever
18 or 19 chevy equinox
and uh the lease came up in december of
2021 and like earlier in july august she
wanted to trade it in and get a new car
because she was already over it right
she took it to carmax and her lease
payoff was around 17 000
and they offered her 15 200 for the car
so she didn't have the money at the time
to to pay off the difference and trade
it in she didn't really want a negative
equity so she said okay i'll just wait
till december pay my payments and then
i'll turn the lease in no problem
so november comes around this is only
what three months ago and i told her
just take it back to carmax see what
they say
they re-evaluated the same car with 1
000 more miles on it and five or six
months older
for 23 000
the card appreciated eight thousand
dollars the car brand new in 2019
was less money than twenty three
thousand dollars
so
a used car that is
two and a half three years old at this
point
is worth more than it was new
in 2019 trade-in
that means they're going to take the car
for 23 000 they're gonna spend about a
thousand dollars reconditioning it and
they're gonna list it for 29.99
that car was twenty three thousand
twenty two thousand five hundred dollars
new
and now it's 29 nine used with about 18
000 miles on it at the time
does that seem logical yeah i mean it's
crazy it's crazy but that's that's true
for teslas it's true
yeah so
just think of this narrative
at what point does the ball drop so my
sister-in-law goes and buys a new car
right there's new inventory sitting all
across the country waiting for these
chips that we're all waiting for right
the world's waiting for chips ship
shortage is real
there's hundreds of thousands of cars
across the country sitting in storage
lots and ports and here and there
waiting to be sold
so the guy that buys the 2019
car for 29.99 plus sales tax plus fees
is in the car for 34 thousand dollars
what happens when the 2023 version comes
out and the msrp is still 20 2 500
right because eventually there's going
to be enough of those cars
right
for us to be able to buy them at a
normal price again because the dealer
can't sell everything for ten thousand
dollars over sticker forever
manufacturers are going to make a
hundred thousand a month
there's not going to be enough people
to trade in the 2019 that they're upside
down now consider the value as truly 15
250
only eight months earlier right six
months earlier
so he's in it for thirty four thousand
he now legitimately bought this car for
almost twenty thousand dollars more
than it was truly worth six months
before
now when you take that on a scale of a
car like a ford gt or a mercy logo or
some huge number and you add 10 12 20
the absorption rate is easier but if you
take it and you say 110
markup
on a used car the ball's got to drop
right because that person that wants a
new car in 2024
cannot get any how could they get out of
that car yeah they're upside down 100 in
value right and that's if they have a
three or four percent interest rate and
they've paid it down some imagine if
they have a 12 15 interest rate the car
is going to cost them 50 000
right so like
the used car market is gonna destroy
america's finances eventually when is
that going to happen
i mean the chip shortage like
we have to follow what's happening with
kovid because covet in america is a
little bit less than covetous other in
other countries right like the asian
countries are a little more strict
european countries are a little more
strict so they're like blocking the
manufacturing plants from working right
i mean here we kind of like go to work
and do our daily thing we wear a mask
and you know we appreciate the news
every night but at the end of the day
like life's kind of normal in america
yeah right like no one's like scared to
go to work i think at this point but
like in you know china i heard and read
that they have a lockdown where you're
only allowed to leave every two days
from your house to go shopping
so like if all those chips and all those
things are coming from those regions
when does it end right i think this is
going to probably persist through this
year and probably the beginning of next
year
but there's only so many people that can
buy a new car
and when this value started to go crazy
it was because so many people got out of
lockdown and was like i'm buying my
dream car or i'm spending all of my
money right like i don't want to sit
here anymore
so how do you determine when it ends
probably ends like
in a year i mean it can't go farther
than that because they're the
dealerships have to sell cars right and
the banks have to give loans and the
salesmen have to sell cars and then they
have to service them so like there's a
huge circle that we have to feed
you know
so eventually
you're not going to be able to trade in
your car and get a new one
where do you invest your money right now
i'm investing in land
land is the only thing that i can see
putting my money into they don't make
more land they just they have enough
right in vegas
anywhere the land is just finite so um i
do have land in the sandbox which is
great there we go
just in case metaverse land is worth way
more than real land one day i'll have
one i'm curious if it will be we'll see
yeah
i have a board ape okay so i'm a partner
with steve aoki and aboard ape which is
cool um
kind of gambling in the nft market a
little bit because i don't understand it
and things that i understand i kind of
want to participate because i feel like
there's a lot way smarter people out
there making the making the rules but
land cars i have
probably
50
of my investments in because i know them
very well
right that's the one thing that i think
i'm the best at
but how about this for the viewers
watching if you have one car that you
could buy that you think is undervalued
today that you think five years from now
is going to be worth more what would
that car be
is there a price point that i can set up
just give give any any car gosh this is
a tough one
the older acura nsx is undervalued
that's like a sub 100 000 car and i
think those are going to be mid mid 150s
i think there's a 50 appreciation in
that
the gated
gallardos are like 125 000 right now i
think those are 250 000 cars right your
car ford gt0506
are like high threes mid force those are
600 700 000 cars for sure
just like a carrera gt it's about the
same number production numbers in that
and the cgt's went from 700 to 2 million
overnight
um in the big hyper cars the koenigsegg
ccx the one i took you into that's a
five million dollar car and those
they're very rare but they're between
one and a half to two point five million
so that's a double
lfa i think reached its pinnacle i think
the car is a million dollar car nothing
more right there's so many unique cars
like the mercy logo that haven't sold
lps haven't sold at auction yet that we
don't really know where they're going to
go
i bought a
2010 mercenary sv which is a hard
there's less than 100 in america there's
no real finite number of that
i think that's a 1.5 million dollar car
because there's only like 30 or 40 of
them right and it was the final edition
v12 that made the biggest impact yeah i
paid 7.50
right so for me to pay 750 i kind of
feel like there's a minimum 50 percent
appreciation in that car within 12
months what about for jack if jack wants
to impress a girl mazda miata that's the
next car i think i want so badly but
they're so expensive they're like
probably 20 grand now huh i was looking
at mazda's i don't even know maybe like
two years ago because my friend bought 1
000 bucks i bet yeah no they were like 3
500.
yeah my friend bought one for 600
and there was just one stuck lifter
forty dollars to fix it and then it ran
perfectly oh wow what a cool car yeah so
i for you honestly i i know he can uh
relate lotus exige
i think that's expensive no no they're
40 grand
40 000 car now there because there's a
there's a tad there's a few of them that
are 60.
2010 2012 they're a little bit more but
if you get a 2006 lotus exige you're
like i think 40s hard to find
50s now
i was looking i was looking if the right
one came up i would do it it's the best
car
i've owned in my life at the when i was
22 i bought my first lotus i bought a
07xz
for 21 000. from carmax they had a
little carmax auction and i bought that
car it was the greatest experience you
could ever imagine it's a miata
in every respect but it looks like a
supercar well it is a super i would say
a lotus elise it's easy
right now about 40. yeah i've seen lotus
releases like i sold one for 16 000
bucks one time my gosh yeah it was crazy
i feel like the lotuses right now are
artificially inflated a little bit
that's a very unique car
and it has a very young demographic that
likes it and so right now with crypto
the young kids have a lot of money so
there's a lot more inflation in that car
but those cars typically sit at the 30
to 40 range and that's like the best
deal i don't know if that's good for no
i mean if i'm gonna know if i'm gonna
spend 30 to 40 i'll buy a tesla one or
three because you know what i'm sorry i
i saw that i saw that
the corners of your mouth flickered down
real quick i just i i don't know like i
can't get behind this i have a plaid i
mean that's what my wife drives she
traded her urus for a plaid she's she's
crazy to me i just can't relate to her i
don't know why the reason why i am now
very gung-ho on getting an electric car
is because i was reconciling all of my
accounts for like last year figured out
how much i spent in gas alone
forty six hundred dollars yeah but
imagine how much you're spending in
electricity i don't i don't think it's
gonna be it's big now that supercharging
is costing people money yeah true i
don't think there's that much of a
difference anymore oh gosh supercharging
is expensive it's like i had so many
miles but yeah yeah but gas is like 70.
yeah imagine you're spending 60 on
electricity versus a honey you know 100
percent sure all right gas it's not that
much less
i can't get my head around
driving an electric car
as my only car
right like i could have i wish that like
rolls royces and like really nice sedans
were electric because they'd be way
better right but like as my only car
you end up with no soul i mean you you
just if you're a car guy that's a real
problem yeah you could beat every car
it's super fast but i mean at the end of
the day like it doesn't give you that
emotion and that's the issue i have with
these electric cars the poor's take on
turbo s i owned one for a very short
time it got someone t-boned me
unfortunately and i didn't replace it
with another one but that car had some
weird futuristic sounds it would make
and it really tried to put a porsche
back into an electric car and i think
they did the best job at it so the model
three it's like 60 grand right 70 grand
model three is now
it used to be 35. but now it's like 47
or something yeah that's going to take
so much you could buy a new one for less
but you have to wait about a year yeah
they're so backed up yeah or you could
buy a used one and pay eight grand oh it
just jumped to ten thousand percent
twenty five percent it's i've never
driven a model three yeah and that that
short wheelbase may be a little bit more
sporty and maybe have a little bit more
oomph i guess uh i have a brand new
plaid like the 22 or whatever
and i can't handle the yolk wheel i
think it's terrible i just ordered a
regular wheel and i'm putting it on
there myself
but it's too fast and i think that's
like a scary thing like when you really
push that car it makes you sick
like it's too fast i love it do you have
a which tesla do you have model three oh
okay yeah i mean do you like it i do i
love it i mean
what's good about it everything like but
what uh self-driving is incredible okay
sure i love the quietness of the
interior i love the big ipad in front uh
it's it's this smooth it's smooth it's
quick it's uh you know you press the
accelerator it goes instantly
it's quiet
i love the car the storage in the car
too is incredible yeah
i mean you say all valid points
i can't disagree with those things
i just
i don't know
i just i just can't be a fan yet
got it so you you vouch for the lotus
cause graham has a lotus that i actually
wanted to buy off of graham i'm not
gonna sell it best best car ever no
you're not gonna sell it it's a load
evora oh you have a nevora yeah the
voras are great yeah evora's are v6
right so they're like a little bit they
don't they sound cool but i like the
four cylinder sound it sounded nice it
was more analog the evora is a good car
i mean i don't know how much revoir is
now 60
he doesn't drive it though he's got the
ford gt i feel like he's got the rams
everywhere apparently he hasn't been
driving a 40s
2006
60. i drive that the most but he drives
all the time
[Laughter]
it's my favorite car grandma we're like
you almost sell jack uh the lotus and
then jack can sell me his lexus no i'm
never gonna sell i'm not gonna sell the
lettuce i feel like graham and i like
could go to a boxing match and all we
had to do was like talk cars that we
drive and it would make me so mad i
would be like okay with it you know
like it's like people people say i have
a punchable face
it's just so funny i mean
you have cars that people dream to even
sit in i'm a collector i've never seen
him drive the lotus once i have pokemon
cards that i used to use right i mean
i'm down to like throw down and play the
pokemon cards at this point you know i
mean i haven't done it since i was 12 or
13. i still have all those cards but
like i feel like we shouldn't lock them
in a box somewhere and just sit down
work of art you look at it
put it there
i disagree how often do you go look at
your uncut sheet of pokemon cards every
time i go to the past
glance or do you sit there and
appreciate it
it's the same thing
look at this thing for i see it every
time i go and go to the bathroom i see
it on the wall
what am i supposed to do cut cut that
cut it up and play the game yeah no no
i'm just saying no oh yeah let's take
some scissors to that i don't know i
like i like the perspective of like you
utilize the things that you have i think
there's
stuff right i think there's a balance
you know i don't know there's no right
answer to this because everybody has a
different value of what they spend their
money on right i mean i could spend
unbelievable amounts of money on guns i
love guns right but i'd never use them i
never use my guns right i just love
collecting guns i don't really think i
should go use my guns right i think
that's kind of like a weird thing i mean
shooting range every once in a while go
practice but you can only take one or
two or three i like 400 guns you know so
i could relate to collecting because it
looks really cool in my wallet this huge
room it's all events right the intruders
away yeah i guess but they're they're
literally not like they're specialty
things like some are gold and they're
all crazy colors and it's good i don't
really want to go out and just shoot in
my backyard all day right but like with
the cars you can kind of like drive them
in your normal daily routine right i
can't just take a gun with me to work
right i mean i guess i could legally but
yeah it's not really fitting but like
with i could drive my lexus lfa to work
and i can have a great drive on the
freeway 13 minutes of bliss seven miles
on the freeway and just go and have
great time you know i think there's a
balance of that right collecting and
then using but at some point
you're gonna have to realize we spent
money on this and like it wasn't worth
it
money sitting in the bank probably isn't
that funny either right i mean can we
agree anything you know i mean if we
just have it in the bank we're just
losing money to inflation aren't we
there's yes but there is also the
opportunity of you know if a good deal
comes up that you're able to jump on it
yeah i think that's graham's trigger i i
think wasting money is graham's trigger
yeah yes for sure
i like just looking appreciating and uh
and that's it jack let me give you the
only sensible advice in this room let's
hear it don't buy another car that's
there you go
these these these guys right here
they're out of their mind for telling
you to buy a car that's all i'm going to
say st just keep your lexus manager i'm
not wasteful like i'm very i
i waste my money a little bit but it's
on very sm it's like small relatives
what is your advice what i could be food
okay i get i go out for food a lot like
burritos tacos
burgers
yeah but it's not like it's a a lot of
money right so i know that on occasion i
can splurge if i if i so please so i do
want to get another car at some point i
think you should buy a very exciting car
to use to go on all of the food
adventures
and it adds to that experience so every
time you go to some new food place drive
your really cool car
mazda miata would make it top down
it's 60 degrees outside or 50 degrees
heater on windows up oh gosh play some
i don't know
crazy train yeah something awesome there
you go yeah
yeah play something nice and just jam on
the freeway and get a good burger
that'll be the greatest experience that
you can get i agree i mean that's
pretty much what we live for yeah it's
those moments and you have long hair
it'll be like floating oh i'm gonna grow
it out if i get me honest
it'll just be like all over the place
yeah all right i think i think that's
enough jack
all right is there anything else you
want to throw in that's a great thing to
end this video on that
visual emotional visual moment thank you
so much for coming on houston appreciate
opening up my third eye i appreciate it
thanks graeme yeah and thank you guys
for watching make sure by the way we'll
link to your channel down below in the
description make sure to like the video
and get your free stock down below in
the description you may as well it's
worth all the way up to it thank you
guys i really appreciate it and
subscribe
thanks for coming on that was awesome
man it's nice meeting you too